>> So, how will this course help you become a design-minded developer?
>> Well, we're going to go through four lessons.
The first lesson is what is UX? We're going to
learn about the difference between UI and UX,
because there's a lot of misinformation out there. The
second lesson is about how to create applications
for specific users. And we're going to use tools called
personas and use cases. The third lesson is
about mobile design constraints. Because after all, this course
is for mobile developers. And in lesson
four, you're going to learn how to leverage
the power of the Android platform to
make applications that Android users really love.
>> Yeah, in each lesson your going to be introduced
to new concepts and ideas. That you will have
an opportunity to put into practice at the end
of every lesson, in the form of an assignment.
>> And the assignments are going to be
led by a Udacity course designer named Andy.
>> Hello, Andy.
>> Hey, Andy. So Nelsman,
let's briefly talk about a few things
that we're not going to cover in this course.
>> So we're not going to teach you how to
code. You're developers after all. In fact, we have an
Android class made by Udacity. The link is in
the notes below, if you want to take that class.
>> And we're also not going to cover
any Android specific UI elements. So now, let's dive
into what you're going to learn in lesson
lesson. First, we're going to define, what is user experience?
Then, we're going to talk about the difference
between UI and UX. Then we're going to give
you two concrete examples of how you can improve your apps today. But before we
get to all this, let's leave the world of software design. And I want to show
you, a really awesome personal example of
something that captures really amazing user experience design.